These white vessels circulate lymph throughout our bodies.
Lymph is a clear fluid, lacking the red corpuscles which give blood its color.
But all the other components of blood are found in lymph.
The network of lymph vessels has an elaborate security system,
with filters and traps especially designed to detect and deal with invaders.
Vessels here in this vessel.
That is because the vessel belongs to the lymphatic system.
Oh man, how you go?
Ah yes, there are no red corpuscles because there's no oxygen in lymph.
And why so many policemen?
We can't take any chances.
This system leads directly to the bloodstream, you see.
And further on, we'll see even more police at one of the ganglia.
A ganglion, or gland, is a checkpoint which is specifically designed to germs.
Mind your manners.
Are you vitamins trying to jump the queue?
First?
No, I don't know that.
You'll just have to take your turn.
All right, all right.
I won't have vitamins disturbing the peace on my beak.
Constable, she's trying to push in front of me.
That's a bare-faced lie.
- Pushed in front of me.
- And I was the one who got here first.
- We're supposed to take precedence, you know.
- Right, let's have you all lined up then
in alphabetical order.
- I'm straight from the digestive signs I told you about.
- Left or right, Lieutenant?
- Makes no difference.
All roads lead to the ganglion.
You see, even members of the security forces
like ourselves have to be vetted.
- Roly-poly, show me your identity number, please.
Let's see, simply looks all right.
17C8BW7, yes, quite in order, thank you.
17C8BW8.
These numbers don't correspond with the tissue type of this body.
It's probably a simple mistake.
Sort it all out after we've taken you in for questioning.
Then what have we here?
A load of fat globules, officer.
My delivery note reads as follows.
One load of fat globules from the small intestine for urgent delivery to the bloodstream
to be transported via the lymphatic system to the jugular vein.
Down, you globules.
Show some consideration, won't you?
I can hardly hear myself think.
Now stop your nonsense and listen to me.
It's useless talking to this bunch.
Got anything to declare?
Well, man, I think we'll search the vehicle just in case you've got a stowaway.
All right, then. Everybody out.
Suits me. I'm overdue for a short break, actually.
And besides, these fellas won't be needed for quite a while.
There's plenty of fat in the stockpile.
I'll just tip them out for you, shall I?
I thought I said everybody out.
Who are you supposed to be, eh?
I'm a fat globular, of course.
Can you doubt us, officer?
Take a look at my corporation.
Right.
If you're a globule, where's your identity card?
It's giving himself away.
Bules don't carry identity cards.
They're only raw material.
He's a staphylococcus, strained 27C and highly dangerous.
Alert HQ.
Hello.
This is checkpoint 48 calling.
What's your problem?
We need your help, Lieutenant.
We've picked up some staphylococci, strained 27C.
We need specially trained antibodies to deal with them.
Message received, 48.
We're on our way.
Multiple.
Hand again!
And again! And again!
Bodies for Staphylococcus 27-C, now!
Can't hurt us!
How dare he call us little things!
We'll show them!
I'm gonna beat those germs to a mouthful eye on my head!
Lieutenant Clare reporting from Checkpoint 48.
The situation is under control, but we urgently need the sanitation squad to help us mop up.
This is lymph gland 48 calling.
Attention all macrophages. An infection has been suppressed in lymph node number 48.
Mopping up operations are in progress and all macrophages must report for duty without delay.
We may have lost them, but they haven't won the war yet.
There's nothing more for us to do here, so let's get on with our next mission: inspection of the spleen.
Droppy the Staphylococcus lurks undetected in one of young Peter's lymph nodes.
Our old friend Professor Globus and his corpuscle companions are also traveling to the spleen, along a blood vessel.
Yes, I've traveled a long way, my friends. I've seen the cathedrals of the heart and the panoramas of the eyes.
I've heard sweet music in the ears and witnessed all the marvels of this body in my travels.
But I'm tired now. My journey is at an end, and my final resting place will be the spleen.
Come to the lungs with us, Professor. All you need is a breath of fresh air.
Yes, and then we could go on to visit the eyes again.
And the heart, Prof. We'd go through the heart on the way there.
I'm very touched by your concern for me, but 120 days is the lifespan of a red corpuscle.
Does that mean...
Let's just say that I'm going away on a long journey.
Will we ever see you again?
Of course you will, children. There's no need to be upset.
I'll be back along with millions of other corpuscles, just to wait and see. Life must go on.
What are you doing, Professor?
Oh, just dumping my scrap iron.
We red corpuscles seem to accumulate quantities of iron as we get older.
The spleen stores the metal and uses it to create new red corpuscles.
I've come to my appointed hour. I'll take my leave of you.
I'll get cross if you start crying.
Hey, Professor. Other side, Wilbis.
Bye for now, old chap.
Oh.
All managed perfectly well, and remember:
Two million new red corpuscles born every second of the day.
I'm going to miss Professor Globus, you know.
Hey, new red corpuscles, look!
Never, he reminds me of someone.
See what you mean?
I wonder if he'll become a professor when he grows up.
Corpuscles.
Originate here in the lymphatic system, which accounts for the derivation of their name.
Let's be under control here, let's take a look up the splenic vein and along the thoracic duct.
Through here, the beginning of the thoracic duct, biggest lymph vessel in the human body.
For alarm, it's only the liquid made by the digestive system.
Things, this is the biggest reservoir of nutrients in the body.
Watching vessel up ahead, takes out anything that's of use to the body, puts it back into the bloodstream.
Ready to lower the net, Captain.
Look lively then. Lower away, sailor.
Aye, aye, sir.
Has it?
Load it down to the marks, Captain.
Ahead, Mr. Mate.
Listen to it.
The cargo of nutrients, according to the manifest.
You can open the lock gates now.
along the thoracic duct, the Suez Canal of the lymphatic system.
The end of the duct, its contents are poured back into the bloodstream.
Tissue type are you, please?
Good, have you anything to report, Captain?
Just an ordinary catch, the usual, with far too many fats for my liking.
Okay, you can discharge your cargo into the blood.
Ball dude!
Plenty of new cops, there's no shortage of law and order around here.
And now that they've all forgot us,
we'll strike where and when we least expect a surprise as the key lands.
I'm sleeping like a baby.
Okay, men, Indian file.
Wait for the races, ours.
Does that mean their strength is our weakness, Droppy?
Quiet, you dope!
Multiply!
Oink!
Another me, hello me!
You dopes!
Hello!
AHHHHH!
Seventeen in the neck!
Is being overrun by a powerful, well-organized force of Staphylococcus germs!
Seventeen!
So good!
Now, listen to me, my friends.
Before the counter-attack comes, let's seize the opportunity to fill our bellies!
Feed ourselves at the enemy's expense!
Wake him. I don't know what to do. I can't pull his beard any harder.
Have you no respect for our chief?
Yes, but this is an emergency.
I feel a cocky and I've taken over a whole gland.
Oh, I don't believe it. Well, it's like rationally.
Chief, wake up.
Let's try not to panic. I'll have to pull his beard like fury.
I hate to think this, Chief.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Who's that pulling my beard? Stop it, I say. Stop it.
Oh, so it's you.
Really? Well, he started it nicely.
It wasn't me. It wasn't me.
Chief, a real emergency. Look, it's Daphylococcus infection.
Yes, you're quite right.
The situation is serious.
She's got a swollen gland, all right.
Must have picked up an infection somewhere.
Has he been off colour at all recently?
It's a flu, but he got over it.
Hmm.
The flu must have lowered his defences.
No indigestion or tummy aches?
He hasn't complained to me, Doctor.
See?
Well, then, what about cuts and grazes?
No, not as far as I know.
Peter, have you hurt yourself recently?
I don't think so, Mum.
Oh, wait a minute.
I was scratched by an alley cat on my hand.
Look.
Goodness, darling.
You know, Peter's defences were down after his bout of flu,
and if the cat's claws were dirty, then that scratch could be the cause of the infection.
Kind of impressed, I see.
The fever's worse.
What you need, young Peter, is an antibiotic.
Yes, Chief.
Yes, I'd say the situation was serious, all right.
We're not producing enough antibodies to beat them.
The body's defences are most effective in a combined operation.
Three busketeers, Chief.
You know, all for one and one for all.
I think that's an excellent motto.
And now it's a case of all for one poor swollen gland.
Airborne craft are ordered to engage the enemy.
All reserve squadrons, scramble!
That's it, all our reserves, including the macrophages.
Calling all macrophages.
You will report to the front line immediately.
The gland is blocked with debris, and it must be cleared.
Lymphocyte units, prepare to carry out cell division.
Execute.
The line is holding, but it'll be a close-run thing.
Forget the empire buildings, Toppy the First. When I call in outside help, you'll meet your Waterloo.
Powerful help, courtesy of Louis Pasteur and Alexander Fleming.
The antibiotic will give a big boost to his natural defenses.
Peter's condition should show a rapid improvement from now on, so don't worry.
Temporaire, alas, it's bad news.
How bad? Explain yourself.
Look, they're using antibiotics.
Anti-what?